Can a person who does not present with cancer safely use a glutamine for the gut, or should
everyone stay away in case they have cancer cells in their body?
No, I don't think everybody should stay away from it. If you don't have a diagnosis of cancer,
glutamine can be fantastic for healing your gut.
But just like so many supplements, remember a lot of these supplements are supposed to be
supplements. They're supplementing your diet. It's not something you'd stay on forever.
So some people are very routine, and they'll be taking these supplements
for decades. And while some of those might be wise, maybe you need, you're not going to be supplemented.
Maybe you need something because you have heart issues, and you're on something for a certain
condition. Alglue to mean is not one of those things that you stay on for a long period of time.
You should be doing other things to deal with your gut too. You should be investigating
why you have gut problems. You should be investigating. Are you causing inflammation through
dietary means, or toxic means, or something that you're eliminating those? But then you're
trying to heal your gut too. So you're using other things other than glutamate, just glutamate.
You're using, you know, aloe and deglycerized licorice, and you know, slippery element.
You know, there's products that have a mixture of those kind of things in it with some glutamate,
but it's not that you take all the time. So it's taking it for a period of time while you're healing
your gut. But while I say you wouldn't take it continuously all the time, you are probably
continuously damaging your gut. So trying to investigate and reducing the continuous damage you
might be doing, and then working out of gut healing protocol, multiple times per year, and that you
could help heal that.